it's time for roses and rose a my hair
is a mess and so is bachelor in paradise
everybody
the love triangle between Dean Danielle
and Christina is finally over but do
that the way you were expecting not for
me Oh surprise Chrissie 11:00 but we'll
get to it at another wonderful episode
tonight's drinking game is very
dangerous please don't play it but drink
every time Dean says something that
makes you want to go
it started off just like that in the
beginning Robbie and dinner in the pool
and Robbie's like dude why were you like
making out with Danielle what where
Christina could see you and that was
wrought be flipping his hair and Dean's
like what she could see me dude why
didn't you like move her away Dean stop
with this bro code it's a no code for me
okay come on act your age not your shoe
size that's one so Christina had seen
Dina and Danielle and flirting in the
pool last week and she's upset and he's
like I'm gonna go fix this because he's
still playing human girl ping-pong huh
you know but I'll give Dean this he's
like I wish I could be angry at someone
else but like all I can do is be angry
myself yeah and we're all angry at you
too Dean okay okay the fall of Dean from
Bachelorette star to paradise lothario
from Bachelorette stand out to paradise
and took his man's stuff out from
Bachelorette King to paradise mmm sing
it Dean but I don't want to hear
yourself did you make that would be long
word to go back to the streamers
Jazmin what's up with you yeah and then
Blake came back why I just got a all in
do you remember who Blake is I didn't I
had to look up this guy's name he was
wound guy's adversary funny is not wound
and I remember the like site they had
was very fake drama but honestly even in
Bachelorette and really care about this
guy and I definitely so drink every time
somebody comes back and gets a date card
I am very excited to make that second
first impression so Blake's like will
you go out with me
there you go at me I'm sorry will you go
out with me I'm still talking about what
Bill I just wanted to have a chance to
to be me and meet people I'm still
talking about what boom I'm gonna say
I'm not talking about what boom but I'm
still talking about what boom you know
who's not talking about what boom Blake
anybody but you and so nobody wants to
go out with Blake I think so I think you
lose by I don't remember what happened
ably but he's certainly didn't stick
around I love this show but I got
annoyed at this episode you know I'm a
little burnt out on this garbage it's
too much game playing that's the thing
you know you want it to be about love
but especially when these people come in
late they're so just trying to get a
rose and playing the game they keep
calling people their competition that's
fine competition it is game time it's
like it's it's it's a game it's too
gamey for me it's so gay me that at one
point Raven and Adam were throwing food
into each other's mouths and we watched
it for probably 30 seconds why is that
on television we don't need four hours
of this a week
I'm quit clapping at myself okay
priorities bad k problem you know things
that I did 20 years ago
Oh Andrew Fred Fred came back Fred got a
date card
you don't remember Fred Fred if you
don't remember Fred you should
fret that's Blake Blake just fell out of
my hair if I were to ask you on a date
would you be open to it
I'd probably say no one down so Fred was
like the camp goer who's that Rachel
knew in her childhood and on the season
of The Bachelorette
Rachel Lindsey season she just never
gave him a chance she could never get
over what like a troubled child Fred was
which I felt was unfair to Fred I've
interviewed him too shameless cool and I
thought fred was nice and he was cool
but he doesn't make it very far in this
show it's a mini quickie love triangle
between Fred Dominique and Diggy and
Dicky wins by Fred should I like try to
kiss him and see yeah Oh another kind of
game that was played in this episode
drinking every time was on played a game
near Mexico they don't have anything to
do they got a victim apparently somebody
said that Jack stone is not a good
kisser so the other girls like kissed
him to see who's good kisser and Jasmine
disagreed so that was the end of that
game I guess that's friendship you know
honestly that's one of those things if
you are a person with an issue like that
it would
nice if someone told you like if you're
if you know someone who always has bad
breath tell that person difficult words
to say but it will change their lives
[Applause]
speaking of kissing let's just for a
moment take in this moment where I think
Robbie and Amanda and Raven and Adam
were both simultaneously heavy making
out the hot tub it's too much for me
what am i a prude I don't want to see it
isn't that weird isn't that off word
aren't you do you see each other out of
your peripherals or do you keep your
eyes closed the whole time but when you
come up for air do you talk to each
other you acknowledge that you're both
just making out do you say hey does
anybody have a mint oh yeah I have so
that was me I'm dead anyway
Robbie hey now Robbie gets a date card
drink every time somebody gets a date
cards you get a date card you get a date
card
you get a date card where is Oprah I
want to know if Oprah watches this show
but I'm a sucker for family Robbie gets
a date card and of course he takes
Amanda and you know great and I like
Robbie and Amanda I do and I like Robbie
Robbie's always been very nice to me but
sometimes I do wonder if he's just
saying things I guess I should say like
it does this thing where he kind of
looks down and then looks over the
person who's talking you like he's like
I'm just I'm so ready for um you know a
serious relationship
I think it's obvious you know I just
think that yeah I mean kids are in my
future building something that you want
to last takes time I just yeah yeah
marriage is definitely around the corner
like but the most dangerous part of this
game is that a man and Robbie out of
seemingly and some kind of like romantic
date moment there were fireworks for
them but it was so close like right in
front of them sparks flying everywhere
I'm not even really sure if you can call
them fireworks it was just more so a
fire and I was just thinking of all
people in this cast to be in the
situation these two have the most
products in their hair the most step
away from the fire we only want
metaphorical fires not actual ones in
paradise okay guys and nobody here that
I'm interested in so it's pointless to
stay I don't want to potentially take a
rose away from a guy that wants to be
here good for you Ben Z I thought you
left in a very dignified way
love you buddy uh you know honestly what
is baffling is that if anyone I think is
ready for a serious relationship in this
cast
Benzie is one of like the top dudes who
is Oh diggie and Dominique are you know
a thing but I just have a hard time
getting like eyelash extension that is
gone all right everything is so hard
these days open your eyes to the
possibility of love everybody so diggie
and Dominique are a thing but I just
have a hard time getting to like riled
up about them cuz they're both just
pretty chill and seem pretty easygoing
and don't really cause any drama with
anyone so like good for them good for
you good luck to you okay great you're
attractive enjoy it great wonderful DMD
double-deep great Oh Kristen Kristen yes
that's her name learns that her nickname
is scallops
it was Tommy's scallops you know the
scallops story no which is not nice and
then everybody is trying to win
Kristen's heart that Blake guy is Jack
stone is and
[Music]
I think benzene maybe was for a little
while I forget so everybody's trying to
win her heart
and the blade guy does it by bringing
her some scallops oh boy I love scallops
and she eats them all so she said they
were really greasy and then she makes
out with Jack so greasy scallops and too
greasy makeouts
I hate to say it but I mean Christmas
all like there are a lot of fish in my
sea right now how did this happen
[Music]
it is game time Jack stones my down the
fish and again it's a game Blake's like
he's my competition drink every time it
was a game but he cares he cares why
Boone was the fake one not like not like
Blake doesn't ride with me I paid so
then things
apologizes to Christina but then Dean
tells Danielle I want to pursue whatever
with you happy about what what Dean
these are called mixed messages and
you're trying not to hurt anybody but
you're gonna end up hurting everybody
Dean this is the part where you want to
go why Dean why are you doing this
yourself are you okay paradise waters
it's raining the tears of all the fans
who believed in Dean I'm not saying
Dean's a bad person but he's certainly
making some bad choices here in paradise
Dean was a frontrunner to be the
bachelor but then he says this I just
think that I'm not necessarily ready for
like that serious of a relationship I
interviewed him even he said he thinks
he has a lot of maturing to do if he's
gonna be the bachelor so if Dean is then
after Dean and Christina have this
awkward conversation he's like I guess
let's go meet up with everyone I guess
let's go meet up with everyone
they have to like get off that taint bed
together awkward
can't hide from anyone in paradise I'm
your enemy the truth now here was a
moment for women for men for friendship
Cristina's like Danielle got in his head
and Raven who has been playing this
whole season says girl I am gonna give
you the truth and she lays out that
truth he's a lion that is pursuing her
and Christina doesn't like it and she's
very upset about it and then wells also
like sweetly and casually just posed a
question why are you fighting for
someone who's not fighting for you
and that seemed to hit home sometimes
it's hard to listen to your friends
sometimes you got to listen to your kind
of friend who's sort of tennis bar in a
reality-show
setting and the camera really zooms in
on Christina's problem and she takes a
look at herself and we get a rose
ceremony to remember Kristin gives her
rose to Jack and she's like it's really
happy to learn that you're not a serial
killer and some dudes go home and
Christina dead she gives a speech about
valuing herself about respecting herself
about being a woman in bachelor nation
went to be respected and I want to be
put first build up again swirling fire
that will not light your head on fire
with your hairspray but instead will
fire you into the sky from which you
shall see your true love down below you
you shall land you shall collect him you
shall ascend to the heavens and there
you shall be happy what am I talking
about
christina goes home into the like SUV
Mexico uber that's waiting for her and
here's what was interesting dean follows
her Dean why Dean sit down nah no no no
you had your time you had your moment
she didn't ask you to follow her
Christina's like okay
they like hug insuk now and then Deena's
so shaken that he thinks Danielle's not
gonna give him the rose but why wouldn't
she since he told her he picked her she
gives him the rose and that's how it
goes and Dean Kristina
Danielle D lo love triangle is broken
shattered into a million pieces
it was our Illuminati for a while but
now it's just every love triangle has
its chords what did you guys think of
how it ended the love triangle is
finally over and I was surprised by how
things went down I thought I must say
that I don't know I thought Kristina was
gonna like leave before a rose ceremony
ever happened I was pretty shocked when
Dean went to Danielle and was like I
think you because this whole time he was
like Christina's so smart and Danielle's
so hot and like I see a relationship
with Kristina but I basically I guess
I'm just saying I want to do stuff with
Danielle and then he picked Danielle
just and again let's go back and let's
make the take away what Raven said which
is that it is not about woman versus
woman it's about women
let me know what you guys thought of
this episode of bachelor in paradise
this season is worn down we've all spent
four hours of our week every week
investing into it so you must have
thoughts let me know over on Twitter
Instagram or snapchat and of course make
sure to LIKE ET on Facebook subscribe to
us on YouTube also it's fabulous
bachelor context I drink to all of you
to your places in the heavens with other
women and friends and not
but guys I love you to freaking love you
too
but friends till the end relationships
till and so is bachelor in paradise
everybody you know we gotta shake the
chair it's chair there's a lot to say
about all the gas everybody was blowing
up each other's you know wasn't very
nice